there was a lot of reasons why i wanted
to have you on the pod one to catch up
like this it's always fun
yeah uh but number two so much is going
on in real estate
and i was so confused by trying to
understand the market i was like
who do i know who's really smart and i
thought glenn
redfin i wanted to start with what is
your take on what is going on with the
housing
crisis slash bubble slash appreciation
because
i've never seen anything like this and i
lived through the last bubble
the 2008 time when i bought my first
house and so
just generally people are watching
housing prices go through the roof
people migrating i don't get the sense
that a lot of the people in our circles
are selling their original home they're
just buying a second one
and then they're sitting on the first
one because it's appreciating faster
than the stock market
which then is screwing with supply tell
us everything from where you sit because
you have the data
oh wow well i don't know where to start
i think there are two trends and one is
the chickens are coming home to roost
and the other is that the dam is broken
and you've definitely
spoken to that second trend which is
that all this money
built up in san francisco and new york
everyone in pittsburgh
and tulsa oklahoma were talking about
how they could create silicon valley
wherever they were and we never thought
they would but now they finally have
and so i think it's actually good for
the country that
technology expertise the professional
classes can live
anywhere but it does create these social
disruptions
people moving to nashville are paying
nearly twice as much
as the folks who live there for a home
they come in with
monopoly money from new york or
california and they send home prices
shooting through the roof and the reason
that those prices have continued to go
up
is that in san francisco when prices
went up it just reached a natural limit
but for someone moving to boise idaho
you could pay three times as much and
you're still spending less than a
million dollars for a house
so it feels so cheap it's just that the
people who started in boise are suddenly
priced out of the market so this idea
that you could have
a working-class job and be able to
afford the american dream was still
possible in the middle of the country
and that has changed not over a 20-year
period but over a 20-week period
and it's just a massive disruption and
so
that's the first thing is just okay so
we are now all free to move about the
country
yeah yeah so we have the pandemic people
realize they can work from anywhere
big companies paying big salaries to
tech workers information workers
say we want you to come back and then
they realize
oh wait a second we are in a prison's
dilemma here
you know netflix and apple said
you have to come back it's not
negotiable
and then the employers were like yeah
you know we're not coming back i'm gonna
go work at google or twitter or square
because jack believes we can work from
anywhere
and they were like okay you can work
from anywhere because we're not losing
our top talent
that's kind of what happened which means
now people can live anywhere and do that
arbitrage a three million dollar
condo or a house in san francisco a
three or four million dollar brownstone
in brooklyn
now gives way to a million dollar place
in austin and
you feel like wow i'm a genius and the
people in austin
are like you paid a million dollars for
that i paid 600 000
two years ago you're an idiot that's
exactly it and it's a ratchet i've seen
this
over many many moves
the people who suddenly get a three-car
garage
and have a bedroom for each kid never go
back
even if you're a zillionaire you get
addicted to the cost of living
in texas or florida so i think in
florida for every one person who's
leaving the states
seven are coming in in texas it's five
and in general for low tax states
for every person leaving four are coming
in so there's just this great migration
and it's also causing a political
upheaval because
san francisco new york seattle have all
gone through
protests black lives matters a bunch of
issues
that have really roiled the social
fabric and they want to invest in that
and some of them
will call you as an entrepreneur or ceo
and say that we want you to support
higher taxes which is something that
i've always
been supportive of but now when they ask
are you going to leave seattle they act
as if my personal decision
matters when really we don't have one
office in seattle anymore we have a
thousand offices
each employee deciding do i want to live
in florida or north dakota
or texas or utah and they are migrating
to the lowest cost place to do that so i
think it's
actually destroyed some of the leverage
that big cities have had
to raise revenues and solve some social
problems and that's just going to put
more pressure on the federal government
so there's all sorts of fun
implications about it but i think the
second challenge is that we just had so
long
to build housing like for 10 years i've
been saying we just need to build more
housing and we've argued about whether
it should be affordable housing or
housing for rich people it doesn't
really matter because when you increase
the supply
you're going to lower prices overall and
whether it's a left wing person or a
right-wing person we have not been able
to get behind that especially on the
left
you have a lot of nimbyism where people
worry about the character of
neighborhoods they worry about zoning
they don't want density mayors who used
to be proud
to go to a ribbon cutting ceremony with
a developer are
just absolutely averse to that they
wouldn't be caught dead with a developer
because
people are so opposed to growth and so
that's one of the reasons that i ended
up leaving san francisco is just because
the city just stuck its head in the sand
you know i lived in the mission for a
long time which was a very diverse area
it became an absolute tech zone uh by
the time i left and it was because we
couldn't build
any more housing and so that has
happened
from san francisco up to seattle down to
denver out to portland over to boise
the money just arcs from one place to
another in every place
it just wrecks home prices and so i
think that's the other challenge is we
just have to figure out how we can get
very aggressive about building houses
because
this is still an incredible land there's
so much space in america compared to
where you are
anywhere else in the world and we just
have more room to grow we worry about
inflation but i think
one check on that is this idea that we
can just
spread out yes um in a way that no other
country can and so i think that's
happening but i still wish
we could invest more in housing i think
it would help the working class i think
it would help the whole country
listen i know you're gonna feel anxious
buying an expensive suit
and oh my god what if i get a stain on
it and can i afford it
all of those worries and fears
are gonna go away right now because if
you go to indochino
like i just did you will get a perfect
fitting you go in
they've got a great staff they show you
an unbelievable amount of fabrics
all beautifully organized and then they
measure you
perfectly takes like 15 minutes all your
measurements
right into a computer beep beep then
they tell you the price
and i'm like wait a second right is that
the price for one suit
or that's just for the pants or that's
just for the vest or just for the jacket
like no that's the whole that's the
whole price j cal
i was like that's impossible because
3.99 for an incredible suit
with all of this intricate choices you
can pick
the monogram the lapel the linings they
make your suit perfect indochino is now
open at select nordstrom stores giving
you
even more ways to get a great fitting
for your personalized clothing
and you can find your nearest location
at indochino.com
ind o c h i n
o dot com indochino.com use the promo
code twist
and they're gonna give you 50 off any
purchase of 3.99 or more
just by using twist again indochino.com
use the promo code twist it's a really
really great experience